oh I'm scared what's up Hi how are you
yeah we can't help but ask you because I
see you guys hugging and being really
close what's up
you know what I think that's a question
for her
what yeah no you know what I've been
waiting for an answer from her for a
week and she hasn't told me anything
I've been
inside but you're a singer you're used
to crowds going crazy and stuff I'm not
she told me she's like I'm shaking
it's like it's okay you know I've done
it for a while so I'm used to all the
screaming but you know I'm happy to see
her shine how long have you guys known
each other where'd you meet two years
and we met at my birthday party
cool you proud of her actually wait two
years yeah two years it'll be almost
three years are you proud of her I'm
very proud of her she's gone a long way
she's gonna go farther she get to sing
in the movie did you help her at all
like with singing and stuff no I didn't
she did it all on her own but I'm gonna
help her though I'm gonna see what she
can do I'm gonna help him act he's gonna
help me sing how fast that's a
relationship yeah is this everything you
expected Hollywood Boulevard oh for sure
it's awesome I'm very excited screaming
fan yes there's lots of them that's very
cool all right definitely anyway thank
you very much
[Music]